The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE] audio.
We're going to have a series
of lectures on shortest paths.
And one of the big differences
between this module
and the previous one, at least
from a mathematical standpoint,
is that we're
going to be looking
at graphs that have
weights on their edges.
So when Eric talked about
depth first search and breadth
first search in the
last couple of lectures,
we had directed graphs
and undirected graphs.
But we didn't really have
attributes on the edges.
In particular, you have
a much richer class
of problems and
applications if you
allow for weights
on graph edges.
And these weights
can be integers.
They could be real
numbers, irrationals.
They could be negative,
what have you.
And for different
classes of graphs
and different
restrictions on weights,
there's really a set of
shortest path algorithms,
that we'll look at in the
next few lectures, which
are kind of optimized for
a particular application.
So we won't do specific
algorithms today.
But we'll set up the problem.
We'll talk about
the general approach
that most shortest
path algorithms take
to solve a particular
instance of a problem.
And then we'll
close with talking
about a particular property
that's pretty important.
That's called the optimum or
optimal substructure property.
That is a technique that most
shortest path algorithms,
or actually all
shortest path algorithms
use to get efficient complexity.
So asymptotic complexity
is important, obviously.
And we're always looking for
the best algorithm with the best
asymptotic complexity.
And optimal
substructure is a hammer
that we're going
to use to get that.
So the canonical motivation,
of course, for shortest paths
is-- now, if you
want to steal, or I
guess borrow, a
cannon from Caltech
and bring it over
to MIT, then you
want the fastest way of getting
here with your illegal goods.
And you want to find the
shortest way or the fastest
way of getting from one
location to another.
So Google Maps go
from point A to point
B. That's a classic application
of the shortest path problem.
In this case, you could
imagine that distance
would be something that would
be a very simple metric that you
could use for the
weights on the edges.
So for this entire
module, we're going
to be looking at
a graph G V, E, W.
And you know what V and E are.
They're the vertices
and the edges.
And W is a weight function
that maps edges to weights.
And so we're adding
that in here.
And so W would be E to R.
So the set of real numbers.
We're going to be looking
at two different algorithms
in subsequent lectures.
And you'll implement one of
them in your problem set.
The simpler algorithm,
which we'll look at first,
is called Dijkstra, after
Edsger Dijkstra, who
did some similar work in
concurrent programming,
won the Turing Award.
But on the side invented
this cool algorithm--
or at least gets credit for
it-- called Dijkstra's algorithm
that assumes non-negative
weight edges.
So I should really
say non-negative.
So read that as non-negative.
And that has a complexity
of order V log V plus E.
All right.
So this is practically
linear time.
And typically, you're going
to be dominated in many cases
by E. In general, if you talk
about a simple graph, what's
the asymptotic relationship
between E and V?
Can you relate E to V?
Can you give me a bound?
AUDIENCE: V squared.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
V squared, thanks.
That's good.
So you can think of E
as being order V square.
And you can certainly have--
that's worth recursion.
So now, you can kind of
imagine a complete graph.
And a complete
graph is something
that has an edge between
each pair of vertices.
And that's where you'll
get E being k w squared.
So when you say
simple graph, you're
saying you have at most one edge
between any pair of vertices.
A multigraph is
something that could
have multiple edges
between pairs of vertices.
We won't really be
talking about multigraphs
in this sequence of lectures.
But something to think about or
keep in the back of your mind
as we go through
these algorithms.
And so the dominating factor
here, and in many cases really,
is E. And Dijkstra is a
nice algorithm, because it's
linear in the number of edges.
So that's Dijkstra.
And that's the first
of the algorithms
that we'll look at next time.
But we'll see the general
structure of Dijkstra today.
And then there's the
Bellman-Ford algorithm
that works on positive and
negative edges, weight edges.
And this has a
complexity order V E.
So you could imagine a
particular implementation
of Bellman-Ford running
in order V cubed time.
Because E could be V square.
And you've got this
additional E factor.
So it's order V cubed
versus order V log V.
So when you have a
chance, use Dijkstra.
When you're stuck, you'd
want to do Bellman-Ford,
because you have these
negative weight edges.
And one of the challenges
in negative weight edges,
and I'll say a little
bit more as we go along,
is that you end
up having to have
to find cycles that are
of a negative weight,
because they kind of throw off
your shortest path algorithm
if you were just assuming that
shortest path lengths are only
going to decrease.
But when you have negative
weights, you might take a step
and the overall
weight might decrease.
So it's kind of a longer path
in terms of the number of edges.
But the weight is smaller.
And that kind of makes the
algorithm more complicated.
And it has to do more work.
So that's really why there's
a difference between these two
complexities.
And I guarantee you, you'll
understand this much better
after we're done with
the lectures on Dijkstra
and the lectures
on Bellman-Ford.
So that's the set
up for the problem.
That's what we're
going to be looking at.
Let's look at a couple
more definitions
beyond what I have here with
respect to just the notation.
And you can think of path p as
a sequence of vertices-- V0, V1,
et cetera, to Vk.
And this is the path
if Vi, Vi plus 1
belongs to E for 0 less
than or equal to i less than
or equal to k.
So a path is a
sequence of edges.
And each of those edges
has to be in the graph,
has to be in the set of edges E.
And W of p, which is
the weight of the path,
we know that by the weight
of edges, those are easy.
They're given by the W function.
The weight of the path
is simply the summation
of the weights of the edges.
All right.
So fairly obvious definitions.
But obviously, we have to
get these right in order
to actually solve the
problem correctly.
And the shortest path problem
is, as you can imagine,
something that tries to find a
path p that has minimum weight.
So in general, you have
some set up for the problem.
But it comes down
to find p with--
And there are many,
many possible paths.
You have to understand
that there are potentially
an exponential number
of paths in the graphs
that we would consider.
And here's a real
simple example where
you would have an
exponential number of paths.
And we'll come back to this
example later in the lecture.
But let's assume that all
the directions go this way.
And it's a directed graph.
Well, you could have the path
that goes all the way here.
But you could have the
path that goes on top
and all the way this way.
You have basically two choices
on getting to this vertex.
Then you've got,
given the two ways
you have of getting
to this vertex.
You've got four ways
of getting here.
And then, you have eight
ways of getting there.
So on and so forth.
So there's an exponential
number of paths potentially.
The other thing that's
interesting here,
which is important in
terms of this complexity
is, what's interesting
about what you see here
with respect to the complexity
and what you see here.
Anybody want to point that out?
So I have this complexity
here and order VE out there.
What's an interesting
observation
if you look at this board
here and the two complexities?
Anybody?
Yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: It's not a
function of weight.
PROFESSOR: It's not
a function of weight.
Great.
That's definitely
worth recursion.
And I'll let you throw this one.
All the way back
there, all right?
Right.
All right, good.
Good, good.
That was good.
That was better than
what I could do.
No, not really.
But I would've been right
in his hands right there.
Anyway, so that's a great
observation, actually.
And I should have pointed
it out right up front.
But I'm glad I
got it out of you.
W doesn't exist
in the complexity.
This is pretty important.
W could be a large number.
I mean, it could
be 2 raised to 64.
The fact is that there's only
E square different values
possible for a weight, right.
I mean, roughly speaking.
If you have a complete
graph, it's a simple graph,
there's order E square
possible weights.
But the range of the weights
could be exponential.
I could have an edge
weight of 0.0001
and a different edge
weight of 10 raised to 98.
There's nothing
that's stopping me
from doing that or putting
a specification like that.
But the nice thing about
Dijkstra, and Bellman-Ford,
and virtually all
of the algorithms
that are useful in
practice is that they
don't depend on the dynamic
range of the weights.
And so keep that in
mind as you think
of shortest path algorithms.
And we'll talk a little bit
about this in section tomorrow,
or the TAs will, as to why
breadth first search and depth
first search aren't directly
applicable to the shortest path
problem.
And the hint really is the
dynamic range of the weights.
So keep that in mind.
So a couple things why this
is an interesting algorithm,
or interesting problem to solve,
and harder than the problems
we've looked at so far
like sorting and search,
is that you have an
exponential number of paths.
And then the dynamic
range of the weights
can be very, very large.
And it's not linear
by any means.
All right.
So these algorithms are going
to have to have some smarts.
And the optimal
substructure property
that we'll look at towards
the end of today's lecture
will give you a sense of how
these algorithms actually
work in basically linear time.
Or VE, you could
think of that as being
cubic time in terms
of the vertices.
So keep that in mind.
Let's talk a little bit
more about weighted graphs.
I want a little
bit more notation.
And what I have is V0
using path p to Vk.
So I'm going to write
that to say that there's
a particular path of V0 to Vk.
Sometimes I'm searching for the
path p with a minimum weight.
And that's how I'm
going to represent that.
V0, which is a
single vertex path,
is the path from V0 to V0.
So it's really a 0 length path.
And it has weight 0.
So that's one condition.
The other condition
that we need to look at,
which is the other case, is
what if there isn't a path?
So I want to put those
two things together,
the two extremes, and of
course all of the cases
in between, in this definition
of the shortest pathway.
And so I'm going to talk
about the shortest path
value of the weight of the
shortest path between u and v
as delta, u, v. And my
goal is to find delta.
It's also to find the path.
It doesn't help you
very much if you
know that there's a way of
getting from here to Lexington
within 14 miles if you don't
know what that path is, right.
So that's one
aspect of it, which
is you want to get the weight.
But you want to get
the path as well.
And these algorithms
will do that for you.
And in particular,
what we want is
delta u, v to be the minimum
over all the paths W p,
such that p is in fact
the path from u to v.
And this is the case where if
there exists any such path,
and the last thing is you
want this to be infinity,
the weight to be
infinity otherwise.
So if you're only talking about
roads going from here to Tokyo,
should have length infinity.
A little matter of the
Pacific Ocean in between.
So that's the set up
in terms of the numbers
that we want to see.
If you're starting from
a particular point,
you can think of the shortest
path length from your source
as being a 0.
Initially, everything
is infinity
because you haven't
found any paths yet.
And what you're going to do is
try and reduce these infinities
down for all of
the vertices that
are reachable from
the source vertex.
And it's quite possible that
you may be given a graph where
a particular vertices,
or in your set
V, that can't be reached
from the particular source
that you started with.
And for those vertices, you're
going to have your delta u,
v. If v is unreachable from
you, it will stay at infinity.
So let's look at an example.
Let's take-- it's going to
be an iterative process here
of finding the shortest paths.
And so let's take
an example that
corresponds to a
fairly complex graph,
or at least a nontrivial one,
where that's my source vertex.
And I've labeled these
other vertices A through F.
And I have a bunch of edges.
5.
I got one more here.
So that's what's given to me.
And I want to find delta
S plugged in for u.
And A, B, D, et cetera plugged
in for V for this graph.
And let's just do this
manually if you will.
And just trying to do some
kind of breadth first search.
And we do know
breadth first search.
We know depth first search.
You can imagine trying to use
those notions to try and find
the shortest paths here.
So now we have to
prove afterwards
when we are done that these are,
in fact, the shortest paths.
And that's the hard part of it.
But we can certainly try and
fill in some numbers associated
with paths that
we do know about.
So I'm going to say
that the numbers that
are inside each of
these vertices-- d of u
is the current weight.
And so initially, I'm going
to start with D of S being 0,
because that's a source.
And all of these
other ones are going
to have-- I'm not going
to write this down--
but they're going to have
infinity for their D of Vs.
So D of A is infinity.
Do of B is infinity, et cetera.
And what I want to do is
decrease this D number
to the point where I'm confident
that all of the D numbers
that are inside these vertices,
these are the current weights,
or end up being
the delta numbers.
So my algorithm is done when
my d numbers shrink down.
And I got the delta values,
the correct delta values.
But if I wanted to do this,
sort of a seat of the pants
approach, just go off
and try and iteratively
reduce these numbers, you say,
well, this one was infinity.
But clearly, if I start from
S and I follow the edges in S,
I'm going to be able
to mark this as a one.
And similarly here, I'm going
to be able to mark this as a 2.
Now, I could arbitrarily
pick this one
here and this A
vertex, and then start
looking at the edges that
emanate from the A vertex.
And I could go off and mark
this as 6, for example.
And if I start from
here, I'd mark this as 3.
Now, is it in fact
true that 6 equals
delta S comma C equals 6?
No.
What is in fact-- is there a
better way of getting to C?
And what is the weight of that?
What vertex do I
have to go through?
I mean, one way is to go
from S to B to D to C, right?
And that would give me 5 right?
So that's 5.
Can I do better than 5?
Not in this graph.
OK
So it's not the case that the
shortest length path gave you
the smallest weight.
I mean, that was
one example of that.
And I can go on an and
bore you with filling
in all of these numbers.
But you can do that on your own.
And it's really not particularly
edifying to do that.
But you get a sense
of what you need
to be able to do in order
to converge on the delta.
And it might take some doing.
Because you have to somehow
enumerate in an implicit way--
you can't do it in
an explicit way,
because then there'd be an
exponential number of paths.
But you'd have to
implicitly enumerate
all the different ways that you
can possibly get to a vertex
and discover the shortest
path through that process,
all right.
And so we have to be able to
do that in these shortest path
algorithms.
And this is a simple graph
that has positive weights,
non-negative weights with edges.
It gets more complicated when
you have negative weights.
But before I get to that,
there's one other thing
that I want to talk
about here with respect
to discovering the actual path.
So what we did here
was we had delta u,
v that corresponded to the
weight of the shortest path.
But if you want
the path itself, we
need to have a way of finding
the sequence of vertices that
corresponds to the
minimum weight path.
And in particular,
we're going to have
to define what we call the
predecessor relationship.
And so what I have is
d of V is the value
inside the circle, which
is the current weight.
And as d is something
you're very interested in,
eventually you want
it to go to delta.
The other thing that
you're very interested in--
and this is really a fairly
straightforward data structure
corresponding to just the d
number and this predecessor
number.
And pi of V is the predecessor
vertex on the best path to V.
And you said, pi
of S equals NIL.
And then you can think of
this as this is eventually
what we want, and this
gets modified as well.
So right now, when
you're working and trying
to find the path, you
have some particular path
that happens to be
the current best path.
And that's a
sequence of vertices
that you can get by
following the predecessors.
So once you're at a particular
vertex E, you say all right,
right now I can look at pi of
E. And if that points me to C,
then that's good.
I'm going to look at pi of
C. And that might point me
to A, and so on and so forth.
In this particular
instance, pi of E
is going to, when you're finally
done, is going to point to A.
And pi of A is going to point
to S, all right, because that's
the path that is the
best path is this one.
Like so and like that.
And so those are the
two data structures
you need to keep in mind
that you need to iterate on,
this predecessor relationship
and the current distance.
And then this ends
up being delta.
You're done.
And at that point, your
predecessor relationship
is correct.
So that's the set up.
The last complication I
want to talk about here
is negative weights.
And it's, I think, appropriate
to talk about it when
we have Bellman-Ford up here.
Which is really the
general algorithm.
So let's talk about-- so
the first question is why.
Why do these things
exist, other than making
our lives more difficult?
So give me an example.
What is the motivation for a
graph with negative weights?
I mean, I really
would like to know.
The best motivation is
definitely worth recursion.
Then I can use it next time.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
thinking like if your goal,
if your goal [INAUDIBLE].
And some of them cost too much.
Some of them get
you money, and you
want to know what-- you're
trying to find [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Yeah, I mean, I think
that's a good motivation.
I think driving, when
you think about distances
and so on, there's no notion
of a negative distance,
at least physically.
But you can imagine that you
could have a case where you're
getting paid to
drive or something,
or it costs you to drive,
and that would be one.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It sounds
like Monopoly.
So the vertices are
supposed to be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, if you
land on something,
you have to pay rent.
Or sometimes you
land on something
and you actually get money.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Takes you
forward, backwards, right.
Yeah go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that is such
an interesting notion.
Sometimes you may want to go.
And maybe in this
case, you're saying
it's better to take
your distance metric
and go further away in order
to get the best way of getting
there, or something like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Sure.
That'd be good.
Right.
Victor, you had your hand up.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm going to give
[INAUDIBLE] on the highway,
you can't [INAUDIBLE]
distances [INAUDIBLE] negative.
Well, if a government
uses [INAUDIBLE] police
to regulate traffic, then you
might have a negative distance.
Because obviously, you
could go a certain way
minus the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah, that's a good example.
One of the things that
we have to think about
is-- and this is something
that might come up,
by the way, in a problem set
or a quiz-- which is, is there
a way of shifting these weights
to make them all positive?
So the examples we've talked
about, not clear to me
that in the particular
settings that we talked about
that you can somehow
create the base
case to be 0 rather
than being negative.
So it may not be possible
in a particular scenario.
But if you can do
that-- and the reason
I bring this up is if
you can do that, suddenly
instead of using an
order V, E algorithm,
if you can prove correctness
of the final solution
is exactly what you'd have
gotten for the initial problem
certification, you've gone
from an order V, E algorithm
to an order V log V algorithm.
So that's a wonderful
thing to do.
So keep that in mind.
Try and get rid of negative
weight edges if you can
without changing the
problem certification.
I saw a hand back there.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
I thought you were just
asking the question,
if we could do that?
So I was just gettin
ready to answer.
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah, so that's
something to keep in mind.
One example that I think has
come up here, which came up,
I think, the last
time I lectured
was imagine that you're
driving and there
are all these advertisements.
And you get paid to
drive on a freeway.
So the reverse toll.
I mean, it's a reverse toll,
because you get to go there
and you have to
see all these ads.
And then I guess you drive
pretty fast through those ads.
But you have to go through.
And so you get paid to go
through those particular roads.
And then what about
social networks?
I mean, there's liking
people and disliking people.
I mean, that sounds pretty--
that's negative and positive.
One could imagine that
social networks would
have positive weights
and negative weights.
I'm surprised one
of you-- I mean,
I don't have an
account on Facebook.
But presumably, you guys do.
So think of what's the--
yeah, that's right.
Well, I'm not sure
how this works.
But you guys figure it out.
So why?
Reverse tolls, social networks.
Lots of things.
Even if you're not
convinced by the motivation,
I will spend a whole lecture
talking about Bellman-Ford.
So that's just so that's clear.
So the issue with the
negative weight cycles
is something that is worth
spending a minute on.
And I talked about
the fact that you
had an exponential
number of paths.
And that causes a
bit of a problem,
even in the case where
you have positive weights.
And I will revisit that example.
But here's an even
worse problem that
corresponds to negative cycles.
So eventually, you
want to terminate.
The faster you
terminate, and if you
can talk about
asymptotic complexity,
obviously that means
that you've terminated
within a worst
case bound of time.
And if that's
exponential, that's bad.
You'd want it to be small.
But what if you
didn't even terminate?
So suppose you have
something like this
where you have a graph that
has negative weights on some
of the edges.
But others are positive.
So this one has a minus 6.
I think I got those right.
So 2 for minus 6 over
here, 3, 2, 1, and minus 2.
So one thing that you
notice from this graph
is that you got this
annoying cycle here.
That's a negative weight cycle.
And that's why I've picked
this particular example.
Minus 6 plus 2 is minus 4.
Minus 4 plus 3 is minus 1.
So if you had something where
you can't depend on the fact
that the D's are going
to keep reducing.
And that eventually,
they'll stop reducing.
Well, that's true.
Eventually, they'll
stop reducing.
Because they're
lower bounded by 0
when you have positive weight
edges or non-negative weight
edges.
But if you have a graph with
a negative cycle-- and I mean,
this is a recipe for an
infinite loop, right--
in your program,
potentially a bug.
But maybe not even a bug,
not a bug in implementation,
but a bug in the algorithm.
Because this determination
condition isn't set properly.
So you can imagine
that you would
get to B and the
first time-- whoops,
I'm missing a weight here.
So you get to B. And
you say, well, I'm done.
Delta of SB is 4.
But that's not true.
Because you could get to
B. And then you could get
back to B with the weight of 3.
And then you could do it
again with the weight of 2,
and so on and so forth.
So that's a problem.
So what would you like
an algorithm to do?
What would you like the
Bellman-Ford to do here?
It's not the case that
all of the delta values,
that is the shortest
path values,
are undefined for this graph.
Some of them are well defined.
This one, you can't
ever get back to it.
So clearly, delta S, S is 0.
Everybody buy that?
What about this one?
It's 2, right.
Delta S, A is 2.
And everybody buys that,
because there's just no way.
You can't, you don't touch
a negative weight cycle.
You, in fact, don't touch
a negative weight edge.
But more importantly, you don't
touch a negative weight cycle
in order to get
to A. And there's
no way of touching that.
On the other hand,
anything that's in here
you could run many times.
And you could end up with
whatever weight you wanted.
There'd be a minus
infinity weight.
So what you want
an algorithm that
handles in particular
negative cycles,
which are the hard part here.
Negative weights
aren't the hard part
if you can't run through
these edges more than once.
It's actually the negative
cycles that are hard.
And the negative
cycles are going
to make shortest path lengths
indeterminate, but not
necessarily for every
node in the graph,
like this example shows.
So what you want your
Bellman-Ford algorithm to do,
or your shortest
path algorithm that
handles negative
cycles to do, is
to finish in reasonable
amounts of time.
Order V, E will
take and give you
the delta numbers for
all of the vertices
that actually have
finite numbers
and then mark all of
these other vertices
as being indeterminate, or
essentially minus infinity.
OK
So that's your
termination condition.
It's different from the
termination condition
if you simply had
non-negative edge weights.
All right.
So remember, it's cycles that
cause a problem, not just
the edges.
And you have to do
something about the cycles.
But they may not affect the
entire part of the computation.
So if you don't know that
you have a cycle or not,
then you end up with
having to use Bellman-Ford.
And so that also tells you
something which is interesting,
which is Bellman-Ford has
to detect negative cycles.
If Bellman-Ford couldn't
detect negative cycles,
then how could it possibly
be a correct algorithm
for the arbitrary case?
So Dijkstra doesn't
have to do that.
And that's why
Dijkstra is simpler.
All right.
So let me talk about the general
structure of shortest path
algorithms.
And the 2 important notions
that I want to talk about here
are the notion of relaxation,
which we sort of did already
when we ran through
this example.
But I need to formalize that.
And then we'll go back and
revisit this exponential graph
example.
So the general structural
of shortest path algorithms
are as follows.
We're going to initialize for
all u belonging to the vertex
set, we set d v to be infinity.
And we set the
predecessor to be NIL.
And then we'll set
d of S to be 0.
We're talking about a
single source, here.
We'll set that to be 0.
And what we're going to
do is essentially repeat.
Select some edge u comma v.
And I'm not specifying how.
This is going to result
in a different algorithm
depending on the
specifics of how.
But the important notion is that
we're going to relax edge u,
v. And what the notion
of relaxation is
is that you're
going to look at it.
And you'll say, well, if d
of v is greater than d of u
plus w u, v, then I've
discovered a better
way of getting to v
then I currently know.
So d of v would
currently be infinity,
which means I haven't found
a way of getting to v yet.
But I know that d of u, for
example, is a finite number.
And I do know that this edge
exists from u to v, which
means that I can update
the value of d of v.
And that's what we call
relaxation of the edge u, v.
And so what you do here
is if the if is true,
then you set d, v to
be d, u plus w u, v.
And you'll also update the
predecessor relationship,
because the current
best predecessor for v
is going to be u.
So that's the notion
of relaxation.
And I kind of ran
out of room here.
But you keep doing this.
This repeat.
So what is the repeat?
Well, the repeat
is until all edges
have d of v less than or
equal to d of u plus w u, v.
And the assumption here is that
you have no negative cycles.
We need a different structure.
The notion of relaxation is
still going to be relevant.
But don't think
of this structure
as being the structure
that Bellman-Ford uses,
or algorithms that can
handle negative cycles use.
So hopefully, you got
the notion of relaxation,
which is from a
pictorial standpoint,
it's simply
something that we did
when we looked at updating the
value of 6 to 5, for example.
So we said through
this process, if I
relax this particular edge
and d was already set up--
let's say d, the
vertex here had 3.
And this was originally 6.
And I look at it and
I say, D of C is 6.
On other hand, 6
is greater than d
of the vertex D, which
happens to be 3 plus 2.
And since 5 is less than
6, I can relax this edge
and update the value of 6 to 5.
And then I update the
predecessor relationship
to have a pi of
C to be D. That's
the notion of relaxation.
Fundamental notion.
Going to use it in every
algorithm that we talk about.
When do you stop?
Well, when you don't
have negative cycles,
there's a fairly clean
termination condition,
which says that you can't relax
any of the edges any more.
OK You get to the
point where you
have values that are
associated with each
of these vertices inside.
And it doesn't matter
what edge you pick,
you can't improve them.
So this termination
condition, it
could involve an order E check.
So we're not talking
complexity here
yet in terms of being efficient.
But you can imagine when I
say until all edges cannot be
relaxed, that you'd have
to look at all the edges.
And if any one of
them can be relaxed,
it's possible that another
one can now be relaxed.
So you've got to keep going
until you get to the point
where none of the
edges can be relaxed.
So this is a brute
force algorithm.
And it'll work.
It'll just be slow.
It'll work for known
negative cycles.
And if you just kind of
randomly select these edges
and just keep
going, I'll give you
an example where it works
pretty badly in a minute.
But this is an algorithm.
So I guess I lied
when I said we weren't
going to give you an algorithm.
It is an algorithm.
It's just an algorithm that
you never want to implement.
You do want to implement
the relaxation condition.
But not this random way of
selecting edges and having
this termination condition
that, in of itself,
is an order E check.
And one of the
reasons why you don't
want to implement this
algorithm is coming up shortly
in our exponential
graph example.
But let me make sure
that people aren't bored.
Any questions about
the general structure,
relaxation, anything?
Are we good?
OK.
So you guys, I walk away
from lecture thinking
I've given this spectacular
lecture and everybody
understands.
And then Victor tells
me when he shows up
in section in the
morning, he says
did people understand graphs?
And everyone says no.
Or did people understand x?
And people say no.
So at least tomorrow, tell
Victor that you understood.
Whether you did or not.
So then I feel better.
AUDIENCE: That's going to
make my life real easy.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So good.
Well, you probably like
hearing stuff from Victor
better than me anyway.
That's the secret here, right?
All right, so one
of the reasons why
you don't want to
implement this algorithm
is precisely this
example that I put up.
And this is a really neat
example that I like a lot,
because it points out
two different things.
It points out that
exponential number
of paths, an exponential
number of paths in a graph,
could cause a problem
with this algorithm.
The other thing
that it points out
is that we got issues
with the weights of edges.
One of the nice observations
one of you made earlier on
is that we had these neat
algorithms that did not
depend on the dynamic
range of the weights.
So let's just say
that I in fact had
an exponential range
for the weights.
I know 4 isn't exponential,
but at some level,
you could imagine that
it's exponentially
related to 1 or 2.
And the point here
is that if I created
a graph that looked like this,
where I have V4, V5, V6, V7,
V8, and it had this
structure, then
I'm going to end
up having something
like 2 raised to n
over 2 weight if I
have n vertices in this graph.
Or at least the dynamic
range of these weights
is going to be 2 raised
to n divided by 2.
Everybody buy that?
So think of this graph as being
a fragment of this large graph,
which where n could
be 100 and the weights
could be 2 raised to 50.
And 2 raised to
50 isn't a number
that we can't handle
on a computer, right?
It's still less
than 64 bits, right?
So it's a pretty
reasonable example.
And we talked about multiple
precision arithmetic,
infinite precision arithmetic.
So we can handle
arbitrary numbers
of an arbitrary position.
So there's nothing
that's stopping us
from putting square root of
2 and all sorts of things.
We won't do imaginary numbers.
But you could imagine
putting numbers
with a high dynamic range as
edges in a particular graph
and expect the Dijkstra,
assuming that all of the edges
are non-negative, that Dijkstra
should be able to run on it.
So what happens
with this example?
Well, with this example,
here's what happens.
Let's say that I
ran this algorithm.
And initially, I just
followed this chain here.
And I get-- this
starts with a 0.
And this is a 4, because
I get there with 4.
This one is 8.
And this is 10.
And this is 12, 13, 14.
And that's the initial pass.
That's the selection.
What ends up happening is that
you could now relax at this--
you see 14.
And let's say you
relax this edge.
You see that 12 and 14,
you've turned that into 13.
And then when you relax this
edge, this turns into 12.
So you go through that process.
Now, this one stays 12.
But now you relax this edge.
And so this 12 becomes 10.
And then when this
changes, you need
to-- if you relax
this edge first,
then this 13 is
going to become 11.
It doesn't really matter.
This becomes, I guess, 11.
And-- is that right?
Yup.
This is 11 and
that's 11 as well.
It might start out
being 12 if you
relax this edge and that edge.
So you might go to 12 to
11, and so on and so forth.
So for a pathological ordering,
I won't belabor the point.
But you see that you're
going 14, 13, 12,
11 with a bad ordering
that corresponds
to the selection of the edges.
And so if the overall weight
here and overall weight here,
when you start
out with, is going
to be order 2
raised to n over 2.
OK And you could be, in
this particular graph,
relaxing edges an
exponential number of times
in order to finish.
And so the number of
times you relax an edge
could be of the
order of the weights
that you start out with.
And that makes this algorithm
an exponential time algorithm.
So clearly, we have
to do better than that
when it comes to
Dijkstra or Bellman-Ford.
So how are we going to
do better than that?
Yeah, question back there.
AUDIENCE: Is it an
issue that we're
starting at the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You're exactly right.
There's an issue with the
ordering that we've chosen.
But what you have to show
is that for any graph,
the particular ordering
that you choose
will result in V log V plus
E and so on and so forth.
So you're exactly right.
I mean, it's an issue with
the ordering we've chosen.
This is a pathological ordering.
It's just meaning
to say that we have
to be careful about
how we select.
If you selected wrong,
you've got problems.
And so the purpose
of next week is
going to be how do we
select these edges properly.
And so I leave you
with this notion of,
very simple notion of,
optimal substructure using
two very simple
terms that you can
prove in literally
a line of text.
And the first one says as
subpaths of a shortest path
are shortest paths.
And all that means is if I
had V0, and I went to V1,
and I went to V2, and
these are paths here.
So this could be p01, p02, p03.
And so there are many vertices
potentially between V0 and V1.
And if you tell me
that V0 through V3,
the concatenation of
p01, p02, and, sorry, p03
are a shortest path.
If this is an SP,
shortest path, then that
implies that each of these
are shortest paths as well.
And that makes sense,
because if in fact there
was a better way of
getting from V0 to V1
that was better than p01, why
would you ever put p01 in here?
You would use that better way.
So very simple.
That's what's called the
optimum substructure property.
And this notion of the
triangle inequality
is also related to that.
And that simply says that if
I have something like this,
that I have V0, V1,
and V2, then when
I look at the delta
value of V0, V1,
and I compare that with the
delta values of V0, V2, and V2,
V1, then this has got to be
smaller than or equal to this
plus that.
And that again makes sense.
Because if this plus this
was smaller than that,
well remember I'm talking
about paths here, not edges.
And the better way
of getting to V1
would be to follow--
go through V2 rather
than following this
path up on top.
Amazingly, these two
notions are going
to be enough to
take this algorithm
and turn it into essentially
a linear time algorithm.
And we'll do that next time.